hi this is Jeff stump director of the
Great Race and this is our ongoing
series of how-to videos for rookies
first-timers and those returning to the
great race movie for the second or third
time and in this how-to video we're
gonna learn how to read the instructions
now let's take a look at the sample set
of instructions that's in the booklet
preparing for the Great Race now on page
32 it's a Appendix II you will see a
simple set of instructions just like
you'll get each morning just before your
start on the great race now there's
numbers down the side and there's
letters across the top so there's
columns a B C and D and down the side
you see one two three four and so on
well we call number one their
instruction number one and obviously the
most important instruction out of the
columns is column a it tells you to turn
right onto us one north from the AG
unquote play house these are actual
instructions from a previous great race
column B is a picture of a tire with 9.0
miles that's telling you it's
approximately nine miles to the next
instruction in that column which you'll
see is it down in instruction six column
C is the time of day start now what
you'll notice on this set of
instructions is everything that looks
like it's in handwriting is what we've
done have written in handwriting that is
not going to be on your instructions the
approximately nine miles to instruction
number six in 2b is not going to be on
the set of instructions that you're
getting these are hints that we're
giving you to help you decipher this set
of instructions column D are hints to
what's going to happen for example
comedy's here says you may encounter
support vehicles without penalty on this
particular day in to instruction two
you'll see that Shore Road and
Beate rotor off to the right but you're
going to follow the road curving to the
left and there's just an information
that the official start is tomorrow on
Beach Street and column D since we've
passed beach that's a little hint to
where we're going to be tomorrow in
instruction three you're going to turn
left at the stop light onto the
interstate and it's telling you this the
fifth stoplight so I think you get the
idea that your main instruction is a and
then followed by B C and D for other
items that you may need now you want to
do every morning you won't do a tire
warm up well that's what's happening
from instructions 1 to 6 we're starting
at instruction 6 at the speed limit 65
mile an hour sign you will notice that
you're going to be that's the start of
the calibration run that's what the
little speedometer says it's going to be
approximately 24 miles that you'll see
in column 6 B and in 6 C it tells you're
going to do 59 excuse me 50 miles per
hour for 29 minutes now instruction 7 it
tells you that at the Kennebunk and
Kennebunkport sign which is on the right
notice the little dot and the arrow the
dot is your car the arrow shows you the
direction you're going there's nothing
in column B but in C it tells you that
you should pass that sign if you're
doing 50 miles an hour after 4 minutes
and 3.4 seconds then it's also got the
cumulative time which since this is the
first time it's the same time you can
see in instruction 8 this sign is on the
left-hand side
Eastern Trail that sign is three minutes
and sixteen point three seconds from the
last sign or seven point or seven
minutes nineteen point seven seconds
cumulative you will do the calibration
all the way through instruction 18 and
if you've done it correctly
you would be twenty eight minutes and
forty three point two seconds now you're
already on the great race if you're
doing this but the official start sign
will not occur until instruction 26 now
you have to do everything up through 25
to be able to know where if the
instruction 26 is but instruction 26 at
the stop sign ahead sign will be the
start of the rally portion of the day
and the rally start time in this example
is 1:40 p.m. and this booklet assumes
that your card number 42 so you add one
forty and forty two as far as time of
day is concerned and you come up with
two twenty two in the afternoon
that you would start at this sign and
you would be doing twenty miles an hour
as it tells you in instructions 20 26
see so when you leave it and at two
twenty two going 20 miles an hour
you'll drive until you get to the stop
sign instruction 27 now that stop Sun
may be a hundred yards or it may be ten
miles you don't know so you drive 20
miles an hour until you get to that stop
sign now you'll notice instruction 27
it's a t-intersection with a turn to the
right there at the stop sign and your
instructions tell you to stop that's why
it's a zero miles per hour and column C
for 15 seconds and then go to 35 miles
an hour
now the rally master makes this course
assuming that you can stop
instantaneously and start
instantaneously he's just measuring the
distance between signs well your car's
not going to be able to do that and in
this example they have determined that
their honor there are only going to stop
for ten point two seconds to be on time
now you will learn how to do that in the
how to make a performance chart section
so the rest of the page instruction 30
instruction 28 at the speed limit 35
sign you will drop your speed from 35 in
the instruction previous you'll see
you're doing 35 to 30 miles an hour at
that speed limit sign now this has just
been a small example of how to read the
instructions use the booklet to learn
more about it you can continue on
through the rest of this practice rally
and read those notes they're very very
helpful to tell you how to do this